It's
not an exaggeration to say that my day is really like 8 customers, so it
takes a lot of time to prepare than business hours,
so before serving, it's
already  It's not an exaggeration to say that 90% of all the
sushi is
prepared
. I hope the owner of the sushi restaurant, Abe. It's
been about 20 years since I started studying sushi.
Club
[Music] I
wake up in the morning and come to the store right
away, but it depends on the day, but on busy days
I wake up around 8:30
and think it's like a store around 9 o'clock Fujii.
[Music] The
staff has done some housework, so I've
broken the victory to some extent.
[Music] The
fish arrived and I checked the quality of it.
I'm from Toyosu, so I'm
a buyer who specializes in home music, so I'm looking forward to having
people in Toyosu buy things that I can talk to on the phone in
advance and
before the fish arrives from Japan.
I'm really happy to shift when I wear something good with both Alice's feelings, but on the other
hand
, what kind of setup is the execution rice ending in a proper
time, for example?  The whole team discusses such things
and then
starts work.
[Music]
The most important thing in making a sushi
is to
talk with the fish and sushi and burn me as it is.
I feel like they're telling me to eat and play or just let me sleep for a while
. I can't hear
the fish, but the best part of the fish is us.
I think that it is the specification of both wheels to put it out, so first of all,
let the water be solid and only the sweetness is
firmly child. The
sushi tax is the style of Doma Izu City,
but Edomae is offered to customers.
Sushi
was born in an era when there was no refrigerator, and it takes time to work on fish. When you think about fresh sushi, you
can pass it at the spa by adding, dyeing, boiling or opening the fish.
Thoughts
Yeah, but it's not like Edo-
mae, and it takes a lot of time before making sushi
.
But
once the store name is 8:30, I think I understand it because I can do
my best
It's not an exaggeration to say that 90% of the sushi has already been decided, so it
's important to prepare the
sushi.
It's very important to get to the setup 1 immediately after taking food and shelter. It's
not just me, but the staff as well.
When I don't
have much time for things other than shorts, it's
almost like a lunch box, so it
's
very important for [music] to break up somewhere and take a break.  I think
[Music] I've
always been told about visiting Korea
because it's a part of my body,
so it's often said that I should take good care of
it.  It's
like fighting illness 3 times a week, saying that it's all together like this
.
Then I copy it to the board,
but this is very important before sushi,
and I'm writing here what's in my head
. Like running to
this white board
, this is the brain of the sushi head.  The
important thing in the head of sushi
is not just to eat Uegami, but to
make it short and enjoy everything as a comprehensive art.
What kind of eyes do customers have
? Beyond each line of sight,
I'm a beautiful Macchan,
so I can't help but sushi.  I'm trying hard to
set up the counter with [Music] I
still want to know that it's about 5 o'clock and
there is a customer around 6 o'clock and everything
is
ready.  I always want to produce
something like that as if I really got on an airplane and came to Japan,
so I talked with the server as a waitress and
I used this bowl for fish.
The
whole team stood at the royal palace while discussing such things, and we all
went together. No
matter how many times we went, the moment the customer was seated and we were in the
future, we were always
nervous.
I'll change my clothes before I say I'm going
to hit it. It's a switch inside me that starts when I hit the apron and close
it.  It's
not just about eating, but
[music]
this energy of the interview by showing the customer trying to teach the
exchange
[music]
showing the teeth in front of the customer.
That's very important,
so it also leads to a lecture.
That part is shorted and becomes one, so
I think that the most important part in making me sushi is shari.
I heard
that it's delicious pasta, and the pasta is
solid and delicious. The old craftsmen often
said that Shari is 80% and the material is 20%.
It's
not just about getting kids out, it's
something else.
Energy
I had them see it before I
ate it, and then I ate it
[music]
and
I saw the smile of the person who provided the food.  After all, 2 is the most
happy for me
[music], and
it's not the emperor twice at about 11:30
[applause]
[music]
I've been maneuvering since the customer returned
.  While
discussing such things with everyone,
I started cleaning around 12 o'clock and finished at around 1 o'clock.
[Music]
I think our job is a job that doesn't have a goal.
If this happens, the answer is correct. Today, we're all heading for this time, and we
're all enjoying our customers
.
Think about the next menu c 0
and
walk for about an hour and then call the fog and what
i it's in
Toyosu It's very important to tell the deadline and time when you're in Toyosu
me
store
I can't crush it because I made it, so
I think it's more than everyone's thoughts. I want
to do my best for the people who supported me with such feelings that I really have to
do it.
It's every day.
Suppression 5
It remains as a proof of each true Tsukubai,
but the moment I saw it,
I thought every night,
and at that time, I feel
like tomorrow.
[  Music
] Hmm
[Music]